we are here with the fabulous caramel
brown
joining us from our los angeles studio
so glad to be here okay mantle your new
skincare line
i mean beyonce promoted it
tell us about it so um when beyonce
promoted it i fainted but to tell you
about this
skincare line so i have um started
balding
early on like in my when i was 26 27
and you know every message that we
receive in the media always tells you
that
if something doesn't look like the rest
of society that it's bad but there was
no products out there for me when i
decided to take the plunge
and love myself authentically and love
my bald head
and so i said you know what if nobody
else wants to do it let me be the one to
do it let me give people who are bald or
balding
a skin care line to make them feel
confident but on top of that our skin
care line
not only helps you with your skin your
neck your scalp
but it also has a community of us saying
hey what led you to this place where you
didn't love yourself what made you real
stop believing in yourself what made you
think that
hair was the only thing that made you
beautiful and i understand that anything
that comes with the physical
you have to deal with the emotional
first you have to deal with the mental
first
and that was the journey i had to go
through well i mean you've helped
so many people and we actually have this
really really really wonderful person
who
would love your help overcoming her
insecurities
i'm going to show you something okay
here roll the tape
hi drew hi caramel my name is ardene
garner i am married with two kids
i'm 44 years old and i want to tell you
about my story of hair loss
so my story of hair loss journey started
back in
2006 i was preparing for this fabulous
christmas party with my family and i had
a hairstyle that i wanted to wear
with some weave in it and it required
some glue
and lo and behold it actually pulled
trunks
of my hair out it was actually
devastating like i
my hair is my identity and everything
connected to me is really about my hair
and i think my hair complements my
appearance
but after i lost my hair i actually
looked like a plug chicken
caramel now i know you struggle with
hair loss
how can i get over my insecurities once
and for all
for goodness sake help me please
thank you so much hello ardene
how are you hi drew hi caramel
i'm doing well thank you i
loved the way that you spoke so
openly and honestly and it's so
vulnerable to put yourself out there and
yet if we don't
we're not going to grow and learn you
your
you speaking in your your package all
got me emotional
and the fact that like drew said you're
being vulnerable you're being honest
and you're sharing your truth is already
the first steps of
healing so that you can feel comfortable
and confident
and walking in your truth and also just
let you know
baby that face is sitting so it doesn't
matter what hairstyle you have
cause let me tell you those eyes that
smile does these cheeks
honey you are giving me life i'm loving
it
thank you so much caramel
just listening to you and drew talk i
was back here
just praising like oh my goodness this
is so inspiring and it's
so true and i want to hook in and i want
to be able to
be authentic because i know i've been
hiding behind the mask for about 14
years and so
i really want to be able to release this
insecurity i have that's connected to my
hair
ardene may i ask your are you wearing a
wig right now do you play with wigs do
you
how do you feel when you're not wearing
one what is your journey right now
so drew yes i am currently wearing a wig
and it is
so uncomfortable because you know again
my
head is a little peanut head and there's
these
gadgets inside these wigs that stick
into my scalp and so i do play with
traditional wigs
and then i do work with the stylist to
get some customized wigs that
are less bothering some um when i'm
wearing them
so arden i got to tell you i got to stop
you really quickly i don't want to
interrupt you but this is going to be
the first lesson i want to give you
you said i have a peanut head that is
some messaging that someone gave to you
that you started to internalize
and so what you have to start doing is
immediately start saying
let me stop saying what is natural and
what was god made about me
as being peanut or being derogatory
because it's not
start saying to yourself under this wig
i have a beautiful head that was
designed for me
perfectly designed for me can you say
that for me i have a beautiful head
i have a beautiful head that was
perfectly designed for me
that was perfectly designed for me yes
that is a beautiful thing because you
have to start to remember that
what are you feeling right now i see you
are you waving yourself what are you
thinking
uh it feels hard to accept that because
that's part of my experience that i've
i've just
hidden from everybody so for me to even
say that i have
a head that is perfectly designed for me
makes me emotional
because i've been through a lot of
things but the baldness has been
something that has been hard for me to
accept and embrace
would this be a moment in a safe space
with drew and i
to start to start that process of not
hiding anymore
would you feel comfortable in taking off
your wig
and taking a step to say look i am
standing in my purpose
i have great reservations but i would be
comfortable because my goal is to step
outside of my comfort zone
so i would accept the challenge to
reveal my beautiful head that has been
shaped just for me
yes yes
we are here and um if you want us to
count you in
you tell us and we will do this together
i have chills in my body i know drew
does too
we can go on the count of three we'll go
backwards
three okay two
one there you go
i gotta tell you um i have i got tears
in my eyes because you look so beautiful
right now
you look stunning and your head is
gorgeous
and i know the bravery that takes what
are you feeling right now
it's hard to even formulate the words
oh
i'm feeling a sense of release
but i'm very emotional because this is a
reveal that i've never
done before
oh and i just feel like i need a deep
breath
what i am seeing is you are so
incredibly stunning
you are so brave you
in some ways made it look easy to be
that brave and i can't imagine what that
was like for you and i hope
there is liberation in return for that
incredible gift that you gave
us and let it be a gift to yourself
because it was you're just you're
incredible
and you are inspiring all of us to take
a deep look
at the things we're not kind about to
ourselves
and you are the example and remember
right now
you've taken the first step and if
tomorrow you don't feel comfortable
it's okay because you can pull back from
this moment of how confident you are
thank you drew and paramore appreciate
you both
thank you guys for this time truly
thank you thank you ardene thank you
caramo
season five already of queer eye is
available on netflix right now ardene
caramo
thank you thank you for this awesome
time
[Music]